aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'avoir un
public qui qui vient en connaissance de
cause donc il vient parce qu'il aime
cette humour là et je pense que tout
simplement c'est un humour qui est quand
même très populaire et moi les gens me
disent souvent à la fin du spectacle en
fait c'est mon humour j'ose pas le faire
en public ou devant mes amis mais c'est
mon humour et du coup j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup de gens pratiquent cette
humour là sans forcément l'assumer donc
ce que vous nous dites Laura c'est que
c'est finalement plus facile maintenant
parce que les gens vous connaissent
votre univers qui a quelques années au
moment où vous avez gagné incroyable
talent par exemple là fallait vraiment
convaincre et oui il y a une différence
en tout cas parce que quand j'ai
commencé je pouvais avoir des gens dans
la salle qui savaient pas du tout à quoi
s'attendre et donc qui était parfois
surpris du côté
pratiquement là aujourd'hui clairement
les gens qui viennent me voir savent ce
qu'ils viennent me voir et viennent pour
ça donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
chouette